the Joe Rogan experience anytime I do
any storm sort of organized exercise I
feel great
why don't you do it more often I need to
it's a weird thing it's like come on oh
that's what I'm talking about it's like
this weird sort of you know you got to
do it but yeah I I offered to make the
decision like because I made this
decision every time I go to a new hotel
when I'm on the road I say this weekend
and then a workout I pack my gym clothes
I put them in the thing I say okay
tomorrow morning when I get up I'm gonna
go with the champ then I get up in the
morning and then I just like go get
lunch you brush your teeth do you take a
[ __ ] I do the gym I do just go to the
gym yeah it's like don't give yourself
an out the problem is you give yourself
an out yeah like you can't give yourself
an out why do I do that though it's a
steven pressfield's this wrote about it
in the war of art yeah it's a great book
if you haven't read it the war of art
it's a real small book I used to have a
stack of a mice to hand them out to
guests he talks about this thing that we
all have everyone has not just me mean
everybody that does anything has and
it's like this voice in your head that
wants you to do nothing this voice in
your head and he calls it resistance
yeah and he talks about this resistance
that is in your head and that you have
to decide that you are a professional
this is what a professional does a
professional goes to work and they they
they give in to the muse okay the
concept of the muse whether or not it's
real but the concept of the muse is you
settle in and receive creativity almost
like as a divine gift from this magical
entity the muse now whether or not it's
real is not important what's important
is it is if you treat it as if it's real
it does work and what works is if you
dedicate your time and your focus like
realistically
with a professional disciplined effort
to creativity you show up every day like
a professional but you show up to be
creative if you just do it on a regular
basis ideas will come to you where are
these ideas coming from well his his
concept was to think of it as you are a
professional and you're getting these
ideas from the muse and this will you do
show up
but you do the work you focus on it and
these ideas will come to you and that's
really true if you really stop and think
about it if you write something whether
it's the most brilliant thing you've
ever written or whether you're not good
at editing and it turns out to be
[ __ ]
you're still it's where is that coming
from man you're just sitting down in
front of your laptop and these thoughts
are coming to you and all of a sudden
you're talking about a kid who's riding
a bike and he gets attacked by a
werewolf like where the [ __ ] is this
coming from if it's not coming from the
muse where is it coming from well it's
good for my creativity okay do you know
how to access your creativity like you
can blink no you don't you do do I
access your activity like you can lick
something or perform any sort of
physical functions repeatable no you
don't it's a non repeatable thing treat
it like it's magic but treat it like
you're a professional and you show up to
engage with the magic so every day at
the same time you sit down in front of
you keyboard and you start working mhm
and just put in the work and put in the
work and force yourself to do it
do you force it like a muscle like the
same muscle that you develop when you go
running every day and then you get to
the point where like seven days in you
start [ __ ] feeling good run it right
right so you start to feel like you're
good at it
you start feeling like you're getting
better yeah because you're putting in
the time
[Applause]